sidy diallo 61 ans est un mordu de
course à pied ligne montrent un réalisé
en 5 ans et demi cent trente trois
marathons et 9 ultramar à tour dans 51
pays sur cinq continents sur l'addiction
running et récente le sportif a disputé
son premier 42 km le 10 octobre 2010 à
chicago jusqu'à 1 2000
10 gt comme les 7 milliards
du 1 du main qui pensaient que le maroc
lance et c'est pas pour eux c'est déjà
exceptionnel
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir été affecté à
chicago ensuite général adjoint de
france et le marathon de chicago est
extrêmement populaire
donc pendant deux ans j'ai applaudi le
coureur et puis la troisième année j'ai
décidé de me faire applaudir par les
autres
très vite sidy diallo est devenu accro
au marathon le sportif en totalise 48
sur l'année 2013 et réalise son meilleur
temps en 2012 au marathon de berlin en
allemagne en 3 heures 14 minutes et 13
secondes une performance anecdotique
pour le coureur donc un performance non
c'est l'expérience qui m'intéresse quand
je cours il discute avec les coureurs
tu sens parce que fatigué qui veulent
bien j'ai discuté avec les spectateurs
en octobre dernier ligny montant décidé
d'enlever ses chaussures pour courir
pieds nus à l'occasion du marathon de
zagreb en croatie
depuis cette date l'athlète n'a plus
remis ses baskets en compétition notre
corps est fait pour marcher et courir
pieds nus avec les chaussures alors
quand les gens me voient pieds nus les
coureurs ils disent y'en a qui disent
bravo
on sait très bien mais les autres qui
savent pas où le nord en effet vous lui
avez pas mal fier c'est pas très mal
n'est pas froid aux yeux il n'est pas
chaud parce que les gens ils pensent que
je pense que quelqu'un de bizarre à dire
qu on ne veut plus courir le marathon
est de faire du prochain marathon pour
sidy diallo le 16 juillet dans la
montagne d'andorre une course qu'il
espère courir pieds nus